questo è diventato acqua improvvisamente
oddio che è successo questa volta a
nitra store ed oggi nuovo video speciale
diverso dal solito mi avete scritto
centinaia di commenti in cui mi avete
chiesto di provare un simulatore jeans
lime una app che ti fa fare
liz live quindi ho pensato in questi
trovare solo una rete compresi slime
andremo forme tante tastiere ne ho
scaricato un bel po così vediamo qual è
la più bella
qual è la più divertente e non lo so non
so cosa aspettarmi perché non ho mai
provato un auto che ti fa fare un timer
non ho idea di come stia quindi se la
super cliente di trovarla assieme a voi
se volete vedere altri miti in cui trovo
magari delle altre tra le auto super
tempio particolari lasciato in bella è
che a 10.000 rai
andrò a farne un altro scrivetemi poi i
vostri suggerimenti nei commenti ok
ragazzi allora siamo nella schermata
principale del mio telefono se volete
vedere nello specifico cosa se
il telefono che ho fatto un video
apposito nel mio telefono vi lascio il
link alla fine di questo video anche
vedere cosa se tutte le cartelle
organizzato in cartelle ma se volete
vederlo per quel video perché oggi
andiamo a fare lo zaino virtuale
allora io ne ho sky calcio 1 2 3 4 5 6 o
cliccate 68 e mi sa che ce n'erano anche
altre incredibile
allora proviamo innanzi tutto questo che
mi avete scritto in tantissimi di
provare si chiama super flight simulator
in materia che nell'app store italiano
si chiami simulatore di slide se l'audio
line particolare questa 4 che noi audio
di scienze live comunque andiamo a
creare lo slime quindi mi disse di
scegliere il tipo di sliven stick
increscioso tutti traffi ei water
metallic oakley clay e bloccato non si
sa il perché proprio play dunque quale
proviamo
direi di provare con il floppy che
c'è scritto gira gli ingredienti che
comunque vanno al di là le banche niente
se poi devo scegliere un colore che
colore facciamo uno dei vostri colori
preferiti mite sempre che vi piace un
sacco questo colore fa il giallo poi
davvero rischiare il colore
beh è già rischiato bastati ora posso
scegliere le decorazioni cuoricini orbi
l'inter fiori peer e mettiamo glitter
ma come tutte queste clip con brusche ne
possono essere altri che sogna dicembre
cose basta per me per nient'altro
vabbè lo chiamiamo tori per le prime
ok ora possiamo giocare con il nostro
story spendili slime diciamo essere
visti fuori casa il booking quando
schiacci un manager con le molle e
schiaffi le bolle schiacciamo la polizia
attivamente
[Musica]
quindi questa è un'altra in simul action
viviamo a ogni atto molto da 1 a 10
gli do un sette e mezzo perché comunque
la divertente ricca cosa è tutto
spiccioli se non fossi trani e mi sembra
che le scelte fossero poche quindi gli
do un sette e mezzo per questo voi che
molto gli date a questa hoc da 1 a 10
proviamo velocissimamente a fare un
altro tipo di smartphone comunque
forestieri che sarebbe babolin penso non
gli piace vedere stufa dei rumori
diversi buttiglione mescolare vabbè ad
un tabù le palline rumore delle palline
settimane sono stessa anzi questo adesso
micro francisco silva è diverso
quindi vi diamo il mezzo punto in più ho
fatto perché non pensavo che cambiasse i
suoni in base al time che fai quindi ti
do un 8 fatte sul flight simulator
vediamo ora le prossime che prossima up
questa si chiama di ai vari live maker
wine maker quindi in italiano forse si
chiamano stesso slide mac oppure fare lo
slime che tanto per tifo allora il buon
ex ma perché devi metterlo a destra
vabbè mandò una parte nei mette troppo
mettiamo l'acqua scegliere
col maraldi baiesi non si può mettere
così tanto male ma se poi escono questi
ne a causa giappone si chiama da barba
macché oddio che è successo per tavano
[Musica]
scegliamo il colorante unicorn ok o
bello mi amano far due movimenti
fresconi sono belli sono polveri dello
sniper messaggio dire spargendo una
bolla che lo sta crescendo magicamente è
uscito un fascista
ora se tecnico ma in fondo è pentita
[Musica]
ok ora mi ha passato sta schermata il
signor press vediamo o che mi hanno
messo lo stai manterra prendiamo si
sarebbe in pochi in sentite io che se
c'è stato sul fly fish hanno offerto il
booking dovrebbero togliere la
musichetta di sottofondo non si capisce
[Musica]
oddio se moltiplicato che è successa
continuano e sono in tutto fondo allora
questa home video un otto e mezzo perché
aveva qualche funzione in fiorente fa
quella slime
[Musica]
simulator ciò che puoi anche fare il po
kings pressing queste cose qua
molte volte di date la numero 2 da una
di esse wine maker fatto quindi in
italia fabbrica di sla il motivo ma
prima devo fare la spesa fa allora cosa
contiamo de ficción ok poi posso
prendere qualcun altro no andare avanti
devo prendere il colorante
che prende certe perché non sa prendere
vascello poi parliamo anti carrello
nuovi ticket
no non si muove da offrire
no non voglio perdere ma nasce
[Musica]
contenitore che altro per prendere pausa
acqua mi fa con una certa morante
maurizio rosso sta passando gli oggetti
nella coccarda penso 9 dollari e una
cosa così piccola dei jeans o da 25
dollari colorante poi vabbè rosso
[Musica]
[Applauso]
io non ho volere tutto con la rete bene
brutto ma che per apple cioè un totale
di 109 dollari per queste quattro cose
un po cari qua che mi dice a devo che
lasci il tempo allora dopo prenditi il
colorante verde dove contenitore b fine
un po il contenitore mezzo di boykins
ora come viva ma manca la soluzione per
lenti vabbè poi non so perché ci mettono
l'attivatore prima vabbè poi fare oggi
oltre il motore ci sono macchinari e
gigante
i conti è davvero una fabbrica di klein
[Musica]
quello berle purtroppo perché non lo
voglio
[Musica]
come diventerà rainbow che devo fare
che devo fare la devo fare queste
palline di flight forte nel contenitore
giusto
[Musica]
no non ho centrato verde va bene senza
un impedita che qualcuno lo sa entrato
la ok abbiamo superato la prima fase
ora che di natale o cretino lo slime
non finisce mai la preparazione
[Musica]
un occhio in imbarazzo
le scatole
[Musica]
ora le stà portando nel camion ho chiuso
con lo scotch mettono il camion perché
mi sa fare queste bormina adesso questo
senso finalmente il nostro
[Musica]
scott a questo punto su questo la
fabbrica di slime gli do un 7 perché a
me sinceramente non è piaciuto il fatto
di fare lo sbaglio nella fabbrica e
preferisco carlotta puoi sentire i suoni
e giocarsi sentire i suoni ma magari ad
alcuni piace di più parlo nella fabbrica
quindi da un 7 voi che potevate
quest'altro passiamo ora la loro qua si
chiama news line makes la storia
italiana potrebbe avere un nome diverso
o nel google for ok agli ingredienti qua
bianco quindi innanzitutto
[Musica]
prendiamo l'acqua stiamo qua e la sfida
borico siamo qua basta cucchiaino di voi
o degli ingredienti tra va beh cosa
[Musica]
ok sto mescolando e ho fatto
l'attivatore sto mettendo il colorante
ma la colla dove lo farei uno slang
senza colla ma a noi ecco la cosa che
possono mettere il falcon estivo sembra
che facciano ctb saremo al contrario
forse up
questa è una fotografia
scoliamo tutto vediamo come se devo
sfruttare chi è uscito andiamo avanti
ora ecco che lo posso tirare ma non vada
sul suono serve lo posso non tirare
positiva va beh forse per altro non
posso più fare niente mi sta facendo a
mettere delle cose ma centrano con
l'islam non capisco cosa sono queste
cose cosa c'entra a da mestiere il re
klein
ok ragazzi questa app numero 4 gli do un
sei e mezzo
sinceramente non mi è piaciuta molto mi
ha convinto molto qualche voto di data
questa troveremo incredulo due purtroppo
bisogno di partendo troppo auto e
numerosi questa si chiama making place
line gamefun nell'app store o nel google
store provate a scrivere il gioco
offline slime game
e cioè metterlo poi fare troppa dentro
[Musica]
questo quadro pure
[Applauso]
[Musica]
tu sei questa schiuma da barba infatti
non mischiamo è diventato acqua
improvvisamente vediamo se uscirà
comunque lo slide e cuore senza fatto le
prime a forma di cuore che lo dici tu
[Musica]
oddio
ebbene questa era la app slime game la
numero 5 gli do un sei perché a me non
mi ha divertito molto vuoi che voto gli
dati ad altri 15 ora ultimo purtroppo
perché mi stavo divertendo un sacco
upper numero 7 vediamo come questa
e poi alla fine ci vediamo un vincitore
cosa si chiama chris times live maker
[Musica]
anche questo parla
e c'è anche chi sony trani
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ok o le indica due maniglie proprio
appunto in ita
ma.ma
non fa nel veneto ci sono dice che puoi
anche tirare lo slime fantastico perché
sono chieste ok stabilite di line up gli
do un sei e mezzo era molto finora
secondo me il vincitore di queste per
fare il claim è questo super flight
simulator perché era l'unico che ti
faceva scegliere il cut il timer che ti
faceva sentire bene il suono dello slam
quindi anche se vuoi sentire solo un po
di smr questa mi sembra la migliore di
tutti quindi quella che mi è piaciuta di
più non mi ricordate studio da toto otto
e mezzo ma visto come lennon e altre
questa decisamente si merita un voto più
alto quindi almeno un nome glielo do
spero che continueranno a creare nuove
acque di slide così andiamo a provare
l'azione che siamo caricheranno una app
super fantastica in cui ti sembra
davvero di fare uno slam
fatemi sapere nei commenti se volete che
continui a cercare up laimo
qualcos'altro hop divertenti quello che
volete così farò un nuovo video a
riguardo se vi è piaciuto questo video
mi raccomando non fate un bel like e mi
lasciò ra qua quando una stellina e su
cui potete cliccare per vedere i
prossimi video le mie challenge miei
video divertenti i miei flime click
quello che preferite e buona migliore